these two are fighting and ideas are
banging around in Bella's head in heart
like lights in the storm
oh you're always ready now Bella you're
losing some of your adorable ways peing
I'm a changable feast as are all of we
apparently according to Emerson
disagreed with by Harry come come just
come you were in my son
what
you have to do some of the the usuals
joros you found this novel that was
published in the early '90s you told me
you couldn't believe it hadn't already
been made into a film what was it about
the book hey you're stealing my answers
now well I'm
listening so what was the question then
what was it about the book the book it
was Bella Baxter if you can believe it
um it was it was the main the character
of Bella Baxter which is the main
character but at the same time the book
has a structure which you you learn her
story from other people so other people
tell tell her stories but as soon as I
read it and I imagined making it into a
film I always thought that it should be
her point of view her story that we
would uh bring to life so yeah it was
taken by her the same way that all the
charact the other characters are taken
by her fell in love with her couldn't
just stop reading I hadn't read anything
like it so it's just you know felt uh
natural that I would you know try and
make it it took 12 years but you know we
got there in the
end so you have this story that you love
this character you love how do you bring
Tony into this I mean I think at this
point you guys work pretty well together
but what is the process of of explaining
what you want and then Tony puts his own
spin on
it yeah Tony can speak to that but we've
we've we we worked with Tony together on
the favorite uh so um by that time I had
the the writes of the book uh for quite
a few few years but I could not get
anyone uh to back the development of it
but you know we started working very
closely with element Ed gy and Andrew
low and we were developing a number of
things together so they were you know uh
very supportive so they um yeah they
they they got on board and they said
like yeah let's try and do this too and
then immediately I thought of Tony would
be you know great to adapt it and I I
gave you the book yes he did um and uh
yeah I read the book and had a similar
response to your gos but slightly
different cuz I was like I'd never
adapted to a book and I thought the
baby's brain in the woman's head
probably shouldn't be the first
book I adapt but um we' had a great time
on the favorite and obviously yogos had
a you know a great vision and she was
such a great character and we got the
freedom cuz in the book she's not at the
Cent she's You Don't Know Her internal
Journey it was kind of like us using the
book but also creating it and she was
such a great character and the
opportunity to kind of create this kind
of dialogue was rare so yeah we just uh
started from scratch and we just worked
our way for many years till we got the
script to a good place
so once you officially you have Emma
Emma is your bella how does that change
the
script in any way maybe it
doesn't it doesn't really
um yeah I think it was such a you know
unique creature um that we needed to
focus on on her and the journey uh and
you know then uh just bring someone
brilliant
like Emma to bring her to
life Emma can you talk a little
bit about maybe you're you're you
finally read the script you know about
this character when did you realize that
you you loved her as much as you clearly
do it's like the moment Yus told me
about her right when we finished the
favorite and then I read the script two
years later
something uh I don't know what it was it
was like a
instantaneous um feeling for her and for
the
story um and I loved working with with
yoro on the favorite and Tony as well um
so it that it was it was right away it
it just became more and more you know
love growing and then with that feeling
having to
actually again live up to it was was the
hardest part
so William and Mark what is it like
coming into this like Triad this Bond
here I saw you guys like Mark you were
like hugging Emma like you hadn't seen
her in in years and there's obviously
such love and affection and the two of
you were hugging what's it like when you
get a yoro script and you think oh maybe
I can be part of this
World Mark you go
first well I heard I was getting the
script and I I kind of I was so excited
and then I uh I read it and I
thought I I don't know if I can pull
this off I've never really done anything
like this and um I don't want to suck
for Yos
Lantos uh and so I I kind of tried to
talk about it gave me the
part which he just laughed at me pretty
much and he just
went okay do the impression do the
impression it's
you was that how I do
boss enough of
that and um we'll work on it
later but the the hugging that you're
seeing is you know it's we I had I took
a bunch of pict pictures we had three
weeks of rehearsal and and during that
three weeks we were as idiotic as we
could possibly be with each other we
were as vulnerable as we could be with
each other and we were just playing
games really and um it just developed
this beautiful kind of bond uh between
us and Willam what do you
want same yeah same oh that same
question well uh I remember very well
when yorgos and and Emma called me and
uh I thought that was great because I I
like both of them I know both of their
work and loved them and uh they
described the setup and it sounded great
and uh I was kind of in even before I
read a script if the script was really
bad I'm sure I would have done a lot of
backpedaling but uh but uh you know
people are important that's that's
always something uh you know that you
can you can Bank on other stuff you're
not so sure you got to find it you know
um so it was a no-brainer to uh when
they called I I was really
excited I love when people use the term
no-brainer talking about this film it's
very funny to
me U Willam I want to stay with you
because you have this wonderful
performance but you also have all of
these Prosthetics on your face when did
they tell you that you're going to have
to have this other part oh that was the
first part that was one of the first
things they told me and I said cool no
it's great to work with a mask I mean it
really uh lets you get away from
yourself and leap into something else I
mean it's a tool uh it's I I I've done
it before and I it's really satisfying
because it really States very clearly
you're not there anymore it's it's a
it's a protection I guess um so it's
much easier to pretend and much easier
to inhabit something else as it's being
applied you really see yourself go away
and something else emerge so it's a
really every day you're doing kind of
this great meditation on the on the
character can you guys tell me a little
bit more about the rehearsal process
Emma and I talked about it too because I
was so I wanted to hear about how she
found the walk in the those early days
and it feels like that was a product of
all the time you spent together before
before you started
shooting I mean we had our our
rehearsals for in for yoro film are not
traditional in the sense that you're you
know I don't know rehearsing your lines
and blocking you're sort of playing
games
and doing the scenes but not as they
will be done in the film it's really
more of kind of a bonding experience and
it's funny and playful and what Mark was
describing and then we had jorus and I
just had separate rehearsals just to
work on the walk basically and the
physicality um and so we mapped out five
stages of her
development kind of from you know most
primitive to most evolved and then we
could use those as kind of a reference
while we were um while we were shooting
in case we had to hop around which we
did really only in the beginning have to
hop around
um that was it we just played around
with things and thought about what felt
right and it didn't feel right really to
pull from anything very literal you know
like I tried to watch some videos of
Toddlers and things and then we were
talking about it and you know it's it's
not the same because they're developing
and their bones are growing and hers
aren't and so it just felt like it could
be its own thing and we could invent
that um which was
great confusing because you have to come
up with it but but great um to not have
to you know mimic anything well thank
you guys so much thank you everyone so
much
[Applause]
[Music]
reacting